if I turn around and said you
from today I'm gonna be a virgin yeah
there are some of those
again I'm gonna be a virgin now yeah
everybody forget about don't worry about
the three grandchildren my 36 year old
son I'm gonna be a virgin and I'm not
gonna and anybody else who says to me
that I'm not a virgin I'm gonna sue them
I'm going to go to newspaper and I'm
gonna make I'll be up in arms because I
am now identifying as a virgin and I and
I said to you you have to see me as a
virgin would you feel happy about that
but I think we keep creating examples
that are not very relative to this
conversation obviously being a virgin
that is a very objective thing someone
identifying as a man or woman we've not
been able to identify it we've not been
able to okay what a man and a woman is